do you fear for your life at all i mean
you're an economic hit man you've a
self-described con man who has literally
sat down with presidents prime ministers
dictators some of them haven't made it
out of the
much longer out of the meeting so where
do you stand on fear
i i don't mean to put you down but you
obviously didn't read the new
confessions that economically which was
published in 2016 where i talked about i
was poisoned
uh and lost uh 70 of my large intestine
to a hospital in new york city i was
supposed to speak at the united nations
on a tuesday
on a tuesday i flew up to new york from
florida where i lived at the time
uh on monday
had lunch with this
journalist who it turns out probably was
not a journalist
and that night i lost a little huge
amount of blood in my body was rushed to
linux hill hospital where eventually
they took out 70 of my large intestine
and a lot of the evidence points toward
poison it was never once again never
concluded because by the time we even
suspected it
the part of my intestine had been
removed had been incinerated which they
do immediately as they
built something out of your hospital but
my life was threatened so when i started
writing the book after i was an economic
hitman i started writing a book about my
experiences
and immediately got anonymous phone
calls threatening my life and my infant
daughter's life
and you can imagine pat even you've got
an internet child
and and at the same time i was taken out
to dinner by the president of stone and
webster
a big consulting firm in boston and been
a competitor of my companies that i just
left
and he takes me out today and he says
hey you know you've got a great resume
you were chief economist at one of our
competitors you had 50 people working
for you we'd like to use your resume and
our proposals
uh you don't have to you want to do any
work for us but just let us use your
resume and i'm prepared to write a check
to you tomorrow for five hundred
thousand dollars half a million dollars
this is in the late 80s it was worth
more than it is today which has millions
at this point yeah and uh he said then
he says just don't write the book
so in fact i'm getting the same
treatment that i've been giving these
presidents i'm being offered
you know i'm now without a job i'm
paying profit half a million dollars
in one hand on the other hand
yeah and uh so do you deserve that
treatment though
what does anybody deserve that kind of
treatment i'm asking you i i live a
pretty moral life i don't i don't fear
for my life but
a lot of the stuff you're doing kind of
well i assume comes with the territory
well i wanted to expose what i'd done
and write the book
but i
i took the money uh and i have to say in
my own defense i didn't uh go out and
buy a fence bet but i didn't take the
money i did take the money i didn't buy
a ferrari
uh it's a good car she's looking for her
i know a couple guys that have them yeah
yeah i probably should have
no the way you said that i'm probably
never going to drive that ferrari
there was helicopters all around the
house last night and jen was worried
maybe they were chasing after john i
don't know
i know he's around yeah so i actually
took the money and went back to the
amazon where i'd been a peace corps
volunteer and had such a huge impression
on my life and i've been reading how the
amazon's being destroyed you know so i
go back to the amazon and tell the
indigenous people there the schwa the
outro people i'd lived with i want to
come and help you save your forests
and uh this started me off on a whole
new career they said well if you want to
change save the forest then don't come
here and try to change us it's your oil
companies your your lumber companies
your mining companies it's your dream
in the north it's your dream of big
buildings and
and ferraris and and other such things
that are destroying these forests so
change the dream of your people so i
came back and formed a non-profit called
dream change then pachamama alliance i
began writing books about this
so
you know i i
five hundred thousand dollars to silence
you was kind of the model yeah is that
what it was don't say anything will give
you half a mill don't don't write that
book they're okay with me writing books
on shamanism and indigenous cultures
they encourage that just not on not on
what i'd done
and then my contract was over by 9 11.
i'm in the amazon with a group of people
that i'm taking in to work with the to
save the forest
911 happens
i fly up to new york i go and stand and
look down at that
pit
and i knew i had to write this book and
i'm not saying there's a connection
between what i did in 9 11 but it just
struck me that i had to
write this book and this time i decided
that i wouldn't contact other economic
hitmen and jackals as i'd been doing
before so the word had gotten now that's
why i get the threats this time i
decided i'd write the whole book
completely in secret as a confession not
as an expose but as a confession and i
figured once i got it in the hands of
publishers it would be my insurance
policy
so i went ahead and did that and thought
it was my insurance policy and then
until i got poisoned and
then
then that put a different what year was
this you said you got a family in 1980
uh yeah that's equivalent of 1.7 million
today so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]